[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay i think as uh many of you know
today is international transgender day
of visibility
and we proudly recognize transgender and
gender non-conforming people
and their continued struggle for a life
of equality security
and dignity there is no place for
violence
and discrimination on the basis of
sexual orientation gender identity
or expression or sex characteristics
the department along with our partners
in the united states will lead by
example in the cause of advancing
the human rights of lgbtiq lgbtqi
people around the world now i think you
all remember back in january the
president issued two executive orders
impacting departmental policy with
respect to
transgender individuals executive order
13988 which is entitled
preventing and combating discrimination
on the basis of gender identity or
sexual orientation
and executive order 14004 entitled
enabling all qualified americans to
serve their country in uniform
in response to those executive orders
the department immediately issued
interim guidance
to hold and advance any adverse
personnel actions
initiated under previous departmental
policy and directed the identification
and review of records of any member
involuntarily
separated discharged or denied
re-enlistment
based on gender identity this effort
this review effort is ongoing the
department also identified and initiated
revision to
two dod instructions that affected the
military service of transgender
individuals
dod instruction 6130.03 volume 1
is entitled medical standards for
military service appointment enlistment
or induction and dod instruction 1300.28
which is entitled in-service transition
for transgender service members
today the department is announcing the
publication
of revised editions of these two
instructions
the revised policies in these
instructions
restore the department's original 2016
policies regarding transgender service
specifically they prohibit
discrimination on the basis of gender
identity or an individual's
identification
as transgender they provide a means by
which to asses
access into the military in one's
self-identified gender
provided all appropriate standards are
met
they provide a path for those in service
for medical treatment gender
transition and recognition in one's
self-identified gender
and they seek to protect the privacy of
all service members and to treat them
with dignity and respect at all times
these policies will be effective in 30
days affording the military services the
necessary time to update service level
policies and provide guidance to
commanders
service members medical professionals
and other communities of practice as
appropriate during this period
the department's interim guidance issued
on january 29th
of this year remains in effect
secretary of defense strongly believes
that the all-volunteer force thrives
when it is composed
of diverse americans who can meet the
high standards for military service
in an inclusive force that strengths and
strengthens our national security
posture
as emphasized from his original
statement on this matter and i quote him
here
the united states armed forces are in
the business of defending our fellow
citizens from our enemies foreign
and domestic i believe we accomplish
that mission more effectively
when we represent all our fellow
citizens
he goes on i also believe we should
avail ourselves of the best possible
talent in our population regardless
of gender identity we would be rendering
ourselves
less fit to the task if we excluded from
our ranks
people who meet our standards and who
have the skills and devotion to serve
to service in uniform this is the right
thing to do it is also the smart thing
to do
now today i'm going to ask uh
an expert to come up and handle your
questions about this
specific issue uh and then when that's
done uh i'll come back up and we'll
we'll do other news of the day so now i
would like to introduce
the director of the session policy ms
stephanie miller up to the podium
she'll be available to answer any
questions uh and then as i said we'll
move on
i will moderate the questions for her
that's okay with you
stephanie our first question will come
from
lead about our associated press
hi john thanks um stephanie just a
couple of questions
on numbers um the last numbers i think
that the pentagon released were that
there were
um as many as 14 700
um active duty and reserves were
identified as transgender
do you have any updated numbers on the
number of troops that identify as
transgender
the number of troops who are identified
with gender dysphoria
and then are there any numbers at all
on those who have who were
either not allowed to re-enlist
or faced some sort of um administrative
action over the last two years or so
um that you can at least even give us
some broad
guidelines or broad estimates on some of
those
thank you now thank you i appreciate the
question and i'll see what i can do to
answer all of them
um so as you may be familiar the
department of policy actually prohibits
the discrimination
on the basis of transgender status or
gender identity and in that way we try
to
protect the privacy of individuals but a
subset of the transgender population are
those that
have been medically diagnosed with a
diagnosis of gender dysphoria
and may be seeking um or have completed
medical care
and so we are able to provide some data
as it relates to
those who have had that diagnosis and
are seeking that medical care
and the updated numbers we have are
about 2200
inside the military services as it
pertains to the department's continuing
review of records
of individuals who may have been
adversely impacted under the previous
policy
that work is ongoing and so we're not
prepared to offer any data
on that at this time if an individual
has not been contacted but feels as
though that they were adversely impacted
we certainly encourage them to reach out
to the service concerned or directly to
the department
such that we may um having a
conversation directly with that
individual
can i get a follow-up i just want to
clarify something when you say
2200 you said inside all the military
services
does that include guard and reserve is
that just active duty do you know
um i we will i will verify that for you
i believe it is comprehensive to all but
we will double check
okay tom yeah any sense of the medical
costs that will be involved here
uh going into the future ballpark um
so you know the the medical um data that
we have really indicates that it you
know it's it's very small
you know a handful of a million dollars
per year uh
which is really you know covered within
the the defense health budget
of several billion um so we're not
anticipating with these changes and
policies that there's going to be a
significant
um impact in terms of medical costs
okay back to the phones laura sullivan
did you have one
hey i don't have one for the section
i'll have one later though thanks
okay abraham you had one yes please can
you talk about the
studies that were done and unit cohesion
has that ever come up
uh if so can you give examples here
anecdotally in
where it's been a problem or not been a
problem so today
and this announcement we're really
focused on the release of the two new
instructions
um and we're excited to implement that
policy moving forward
um there is ongoing litigation as it
pertains to to pass policy and so we're
not prepared at this time to
discuss um either previous studies or
the previous policy
so any comments at all on on the impact
on unit cohesion
not at this time okay
well we'll try it again here um caitlyn
kenny stars and stripes
hi thank you um my question is um what
are the requirements
um in these policies for a service
member to ask for
and receive gender affirming surgery and
does the pentagon
have an estimate of how many people
would likely require surgery versus
being treated with hormones or another
treatment thanks
um so really you know we will provide
medically necessary care um
to each individual member as really
prescribed in their medical treatment
plan
uh so that's that's individual for each
case and is certainly determined with
their medical provider
and so it really runs the gamut in terms
of individuals who may only seek
cross-sex hormone therapy versus those
who may pursue
a surgical intervention and so we don't
have data
necessarily available to share today on
the differences um
of of how many people pursue um the the
full spectrum of the plan
but i think it's important to emphasize
that you know all medically necessary
care
to include gender transition um the
surgery will be
available under these new policies
nancy i'm sorry can i ask a clarifying
question on the 2200
number i didn't understand it correctly
does that number include
number of service members who identify
as transgender does that include numbers
of people who are
uh believe that are seeking um
uh surgery i'm trying to understand what
the breakdown
number is specifically right that number
represents those um service members
who've been medically diagnosed with
gender dysphoria or any other related
diagnostic codes
um so the 2200 is the number that we're
presently tracking
in our military health system management
reporting tool
and and we use that for direct and
purchase care um so that's what that
number represents
before the policy change there was some
service members who identified as
transgender who are allowed to sort of
be grandfathered in after that change do
you know what that number is um i don't
have that number
at this time but certainly um those in
that previous grandfathered or exempt
population will be fully covered under
these existing policies
let's collect the phones here
dance a gallon do you have one i have a
question on the next section for you
okay thank you all right uh jeff shovel
thank you uh i apologize that i haven't
seen the instructions
are there any scenarios in which
otherwise
qualified transgender individuals cannot
enlist or be commissioned in the
military
so um the the current the policies that
we're publishing today
one is specific to medical assession
standards and so
um transgender applicants will certainly
need to meet all other medical standards
to include those standards that may be
associated um specifically with a
cross-sex hormone therapy
my previous diagnosis of gender
dysphoria
or any form of surgical intervention so
their specific
uh the standards associated with those
those those medical conditions or
medical
surgical interventions but certainly
individuals that have to meet all other
qualifying standards
in that instruction and if i could
follow up
if the department determines that
transgender individuals were unfairly
separated under the old policy is it
possible they could receive back pay
each situation would have to be looked
at individually which is why
we emphasize that if an individual feels
as though they were adversely impacted
under the previous policies
we encourage them to contact the
department so that we can look at their
case individually
and to provide any manner of redress
that would be appropriate
therese did you have a question for miss
miller
okay dance a gallon pbs my apocalypse i
was having issues with my mute button
can you hear me okay i got you now do
you have a question
yes i actually have a question for the
next section okay
thank you dance a gallon no i've got a
question for the next section
steve lucy
hi yes um do you anticipate any
um any issues regarding
the deployment of people who are
um transgender or at any stage in the
process
um the the policies uh certainly
provide a wide range of options
available both to the member and to the
unit and the medical provider
for for managing situations where the
individual
may need some determination of
individual circumstances so
you know certainly there can be a
discussion under the policy and under a
transgender care
plan of an adjustment of the date of
which a
certain part of the transition process
is to occur such that the individual can
potentially
complete any sort of operational
movement with the
the unit there's the opportunity to
advise the service member of the
availability of options for extended
leave status
or participation in other voluntary
absence programs
as needed there could be an arrangement
for a transfer to another organization
command location or duty status as
needed
um and and really when all of that is
is not appropriate then there there
could be a discussion about um
other courses of action but we we truly
believe that under the auspices of the
policy
that there is flexibility um in most
cases to work with the individual
concerned
and the unit thank you
you got another one even yeah um so the
policy change allows for service members
to
serve in their self-identified gender so
practically how will that be implemented
and how long will it take to implement
that and also would you
um talk a little bit about your office
your position how long has that been
about how many people are in that office
sure so the the current policy is very
closely aligned to the original 2016
policy and the the policy that was in
place for the exempt population of the
grandfathered population that we spoke
about previously
um so the department has been operating
for a number of years
in support of transgender service
members and
affecting that medical transition as
needed um and so when you have the
opportunity to review the policies which
i encourage you to do
it really defines how that process works
and it starts with working with the
medical provider
and receiving that diagnosis of gender
dysphoria and then
the medical provider or a team then
designs a medical transition treatment
plan
and that usually includes you know the
the primary care provider and
endocrinologists
surgical specialists and even case
managers
um we have wonderful teams um that are
led by
regional chairs across the the defense
department and major mtfs
that really specialize in this and are
prepared to work with service members
to help have a successful transition and
so once they design that plan then they
work with the unit concerned and the
commander
making sure that they are looking at the
timing of different
interventions and as i mentioned before
whether or not there needs to be an
adjustment to any of that to help
support the service member and uh
support the unit
and then uh the the command to support
the individual as they affect that
transition
so your office has been around for a
number of years my office has been
around for yes a number of years
and while i am directly responsible for
all aspects of
military sessions policy so essentially
any way that you can come into the
military officer enlisted
because our office has a lot of
expertise in terms of
the medical standards our office was
asked to to really lead the drafting
effort on this policy
all right thank you okay uh
back to the phone alex do you have one
for mrs miller
hey john it's lou martinez can you hear
me yeah i got you
louis do you have a question yes i do
i'm sorry i joined late and i'm not on
your list but
just a question we had seen think tanks
provide numbers of 10
thousand or fifteen thousand members of
the military who self-identify
self-identified
as being transgender uh can you provide
us what that number is and when those
numbers came about
thank you the data the department is
tracking from
some previous studies is it really
ranges anywhere
you know between a thousand to eight
thousand a pretty wide range
uh and and so that really covers the
gamut of individuals who may
self-identify as transgender but not
necessarily who choose to seek a medical
transition
or those who who choose to seek a full
medical transition so it's it's a pretty
wide range so can i ask what is this 14
000 number that i've seen
somewhere else the department had
previously
released information as to again the
number of individuals in our medical
health system
that had received a diagnosis of gender
dysphoria
and as we were talking about a little
bit earlier the the more recent numbers
we have on that is about 2200.
thank you okay tom from talk media
sometimes it takes one minute to unmute
himself
okay paul anthony
john my questions for you okay thank you
yeah paul from afb that was paul
hey my questions also for the later
session sorry
all right great i think we've exhausted
your uh
your your questions for today so thanks
very much of course happy to help thank
you
thank you so much
okay
a couple of other items just that i want
to mention
the current year 2020 quarterly
fourth quarter uh suicide report has
been published on our site
the number of suicide deaths in the
current report are preliminary
and subject to change as previously
unknown cases are
reported in some known cases are further
investigated
in the report you'll see that in the
quarter and again
these numbers uh may likely vary as
um as time goes on there were 99 deaths
by suicide in the active component
57 in the reserve component but at this
time it's
too early to determine whether suicide
rates are going to show an increase or a
decrease
for calendar year 2020. anyway it's up
on
our site and you're welcome to to look
at it
bottom line is of course that the health
safety and well-being of our military
community is paramount
to the readiness of our force every
death by suicide is a tragedy and
everyone
results in a grieving family
for which we should we share that that
grief
also today i wanted to let you know that
the secretary spoke with his indonesian
counterpart the indonesian minister of
defense
prabowo subbianto on the phone
to reaffirm the importance of the
bilateral defense relationship
the minister congratulated secretary
austin on his appointment as secretary
of defense and secretary austin
expressed
his condolences for the recent terrorist
attacks in makassar and jakarta
secretary austin and minister prabowo
discussed the regional security
environment including the challenging
situation in the south china sea as well
as
bilateral defense cooperation and with
that we'll take some questions
lee did you have one for me
sorry uh no i i got one already i'll let
someone else out go ahead
megan uh general van gaarch was here a
couple weeks ago he said dhs had given
them a new request for a extension of
troops on the border has that moved
along at all
i don't have any updates for you on that
yeah tom john the uh
extremism stand down is um wrapping up i
guess in the next few days
um has a secretary received any
preliminary information
from these stand downs across the
services
will there be some sort of a report when
this is all wrapped up and
talk about the next steps if there are
any
uh all fair questions tom uh he's
received some anecdotal feedback from
the
from the services as he's been obviously
meeting with
uh service chiefs and acting service
secretaries on a routine basis about
lots of issues
um we expect that he will have uh
a more formalized chance to get feedback
from the service chiefs
uh next week um where they can uh report
back more of what they've learned and
how they felt the stand downs went from
their perspectives
and that hasn't happened yet um but i
don't anticipate a
written report that will come out of
this again it's going to be a
conversation with the service chiefs
about what they saw what they learned
and whatever inputs they want to provide
to him for his thinking and i won't get
ahead of that thinking
that discussion will certainly inform
the way forward
as i've said before the secretary wants
to make this a continuous
focus for the department uh that it's
something that's it's a
he considers a leadership issue
something that we should be um
thinking about and acting on every
single day um
and uh and sort of an iterative uh in
in an iterative way and not necessarily
uh in some sort of
time-bound uh function so uh well i i
suspect as i said yesterday you know
we'll have more to talk about in terms
of specific
um pursuits uh but it probably will be
about a week or so before we're in a
position to to do that and we've talked
before about how you cannot be an active
member
of an extremist group or you can still
be a member
is that still the case and is that
something he's going to look at maybe
changing
well the policy is it exists now that
the one that that he has inherited
uh says that uh you can be a member but
it's active participation not
active membership but active
participation in extremist
activities or in activities driven by a
group
that is prohibited uh by the ucmj and
you know that's everything from um you
know espousing
um uh this ideology in a public forum to
fundraising to you know and certainly to
any criminal behavior
um as for whether he's going to revisit
the
policy of membership alone as i think
i've said on many occasions
he wants to keep an open mind about
everything going forward um
he wants to hear from the service chiefs
and he'll
i think he'll keep an open mind going
forward about what options he might
pursue and again i don't want to get
ahead of decisions that that he hasn't
decided to make yeah okay
uh tom
thank you thanks john for doing this um
you guys have talked about the critical
aspects of
supply chain and how that relates to
national security and threats to the
supply chain
as part of the review the pentagon is
doing
is the issue of military working dogs
and the supply chain of them going to be
considered
i ask this because the u.s navy graduate
school plot
report this week saying how 90 of our
military working dogs come from overseas
breeders and it's a serious question i
know you're probably laughing i can't
see you but
i'm curious will this be part of the
supply chain survey
i'm not laughing at all tom i mean we
all recognize the uh
critical national security role safety
and security role that working dogs play
um i think there's very few agencies in
the government who uh
who understand that better than the
department of defense i don't have a
specific
um uh announcement to make today about
uh
the degree to which the secretary's
gonna consider this we certainly
have seen that reporting um and uh and i
suspect that you know we'll want to
to get more information before making
any kind of
uh policy decision about this uh but
make no mistake i mean we
we absolutely fully understand the
capabilities
um never mind never mind you know how
how much people obviously
feel affection for dogs but the the
actual security capabilities that these
animals bring to the mission
and we certainly will continue to take
it seriously going forward
thank you yeah uh paul hanley
afp hi john uh can you
uh tell us what was the reason for
general milly's call to
russia and ukraine today and can you
give some details on
why the u.s troops in europe have gone
on a heightened
uh not alert but warning status
well so i would refer you to the the
chairman's office to speak to
his uh to his uh
conversations today um but i
would say that we're concerned about
recent escalations of russian
aggression in eastern ukraine including
violations of the july 2020
ceasefire that led to the deaths of four
ukrainian soldiers
on the 26th of march and the wounding of
two others
russia's destabilizing actions undermine
the de-escalation
intentions that had been achieved
through an osce brokered agreement
back in july of last year additionally
we are aware of ukrainian military
reports concerning russian troop
movements on ukraine's borders we're
discussing
uh our concerns about this increase in
tensions in ceasefire violations and
regional tensions with nato allies
i suspect that the the outreach by uh
the the chairman today
at least as read out by the the
chairman's staff with
uh his russian and ukrainian
counterparts certainly covered
uh this issue and those concerns but i
again refer you to his office for more
specifics
i'd also note that uh the national
security adviser jake sullivan spoke one
day with his ukrainian counterpart the
head of presidential office
andre yermack mr sullivan affirmed the
united states unwavering
support for ukraine's sovereignty
territorial integrity and euro-atlantic
aspirations in the face of continued
russian aggression
can i follow that up just quickly
there's uh um
videos online which are uh not
uh verified but they seem to show
a large amount of russian hardware
moving into
crimea uh can you confirm anything about
that
i cannot no just oh
john is the secretary word that russia
could be preparing
to further its incursion into ukraine
we obviously don't want to see any more
violations of ukrainian territory i'm
not going to speak to intelligence
matters
and just this is not the only military
maneuvers this week you had
uh three russian ballistic missile
submarines going up through the ice in
the north pole
you had uh russian uh bombers flying
around europe nato had to scramble uh
dozens of fighter jets how concerned is
the secretary in this building that the
this is a menacing presence i think
we've been very clear
about um the threats that we see
from um from russia
uh uh across domains you mentioned some
maritime issues you mentioned some error
damage there's certainly cyber
uh threats and we're we're taking them
very very seriously
thank you the uss carrier eisenhower
joined the fight
and jets really made some raids on isis
why was it so necessary for the carrier
to come so close and to join the fight
is it because the
locals are not being able to carry the
fight or there is an uptick
that they needed help what do you have
on this i'm not going to talk about
uh specific operations pierre uh in
terms of
uh you know what missions they're flying
and
and what prompted them one of the great
things about naval forces
is that they're flexible they're agile
they're mobile and uh
um you don't have to uh ask permission
to
to use them uh in any locality um
and you're seeing that bear out right
now with eisenhower being able to
support missions
um in both the european command area of
responsibility as well as the central
command
area of responsibility and that's one of
the the great values of maritime
power specifically uh aircraft carriers
did we need
uh to uh tell the russians and the
syrian regime that we are flying over
their
species i'm not going to speak to
operational uh
the flight paths here from the podium
we will continue to fly and sail and
operate where international law permits
us to do so
therese
um no question for me thank you okay
dancing allen
uh john when lynn rosenthal spoke in
this room
a week and a half ago she talked about
how she was probably going to
pick two more people to be on her
commission and i'm wondering
if there's any news on that where do
things stand on that i don't have an
update i will
ask lynn and see if we have something to
get back to you on that
but i'll take that question any in the
room anything
abraham yeah with those uh
russian movements uh on the eastern
flank of nato
is that has that affected the defender
uh exercise
preparations that are going on to move
lots of
hardware and soldiers to an area in the
balkans i'm not aware of any
uh effect but i would point you to
european command to speak to that with
more specificity
lucas did you have one uh larry kudlow
earlier today on fox said
he's expecting a 10 cut in the defense
budget
can you confirm that is under
consideration i i
can't confirm uh anything specific with
the related to the budget uh
when uh the office of management budget
releases
uh uh uh more information then we can
speak to that but i'm not gonna get
ahead of that process have you heard any
rumors about 80 billion being shaved off
nice try no i'm simply not going to
speculate about the
the budget we're just not at that point
in the process right now and when we get
to that point we'll certainly
uh talk with more specificity with you
uh alex
okay laura you had something
yes i did thanks john i just wanted to
follow up on the situation
in eastern europe um do you have any
information to provide about what type
of russian equipment
you are seeing built up um have they had
any
interaction with u.s personnel whether
kinetic
or electronic interference and how are
our personnel responding i have
nothing to report with respect to any
interactions with
u.s personnel i mean these are uh
ukrainian military reports concerning
russian troop movements on ukraine's
borders
um so i know of no interaction with
american forces whatsoever i am not
going to
speak to uh intelligence matters in
terms of specifically
uh what uh is being reported
uh with respect to those troop movements
uh again these are ukrainian military
reports that
um that there have been russian uh
movements uh there on that border and
again i don't think i'd be
um it wouldn't be prudent for me to go
into any more detail than that
do you have information that this is
more than just a training exercise
on the part of the russians i think
that's one of the reasons
why you know as i said we uh
we've reached out to russia to try to
gain
a little bit more clarity on what
exactly is going on
um and um i i just i i'm not
prepared right now to speak the
specifics of uh
of those conversations as they have just
started nancy is secretary also going to
speak to
his uh russian counterpart i have no
calls i have no calls for the secretary
to announce or speak to you today
nancy um i follow up on that are we to
take because in the statement you read
earlier said that we
have concerns and we're um sharing them
with our nato allies are we to take that
from that then
those concerns will be expressed
primarily through the state department
or
because we've heard of calls now from
general milley but she said
no anticipating positive general
secretary i don't have any calls
by the secretary to speak to uh today
um i i think you did see that chairman
millie may
cost his uh both russian and ukrainian
counterparts and i think it's safe to
assume that this was certainly
a topic of those discussions again i
pointed to his staff for more detail on
that
and then a colleague of mine asked
earlier why european command raised the
watch level
i don't know if you could address that
please so i i can't speak to
specifics uh in terms of
the reports about them raising it
to a certain level
but just process wise so that everybody
understands
a watch condition otherwise known as
watch khan
basically expresses a combatant
commander's concern about a potential
threat
and the ability to provide future
warning so by setting a watch con
basically the commander is is better
able to identify and track the threat
and alert decision makers to emerging
concerns so
it's a way of improving and increasing
a leader's visibility noting that
there's something worth watching and the
word watch is the operative word in
there
um uh that's what a watch con is i i
can't
confirm or speak specifically to what
general walters
uh did or didn't do with respect to his
watch con levels
okay okay uh oh i'm sorry i had
one more jack from foreign policy hey
john before you go
i quick follow up on you said
secretary austin spoke with his
indonesian counterpart today
i i want to make sure i heard you
correctly that's the first time they've
spoken
it is okay thank you you're welcome jack
did you have one
yeah actually just on uh myanmar real
fast uh john
is there any role or does the secretary
see any role for the us military
uh to stop what looks like a potential
civil war there
i i know of no role for the u.s military
uh
with respect to what's going on in burma
you did see however
uh the chiefs of defense from several
different nations including ours
generally make a very firm declarative
statement about what
uh the international community's
expectations are for a professional
military we certainly want to see
an end to this uh violence against the
the people of burma
um in a return to democracy and the
military right now we're calling on the
military to
to affect exactly those two things all
right
thanks everybody
[Music]
[Music]
you